new people are signing up for my
newsletter yep and I send them a few
welcome emails and like in the third or
fourth welcome email I ask them a
question and I say hey what is your
biggest frustration with learning to
scale your YouTube channel then hit
reply and let me know people hit reply
and they say oh I'm really struggling
with how to make thumbnails I'm really
struggling with uh like building up my
content calendar you know whatever it is
all of those replies you put into a
label in Gmail or use zapier to put into
something else and now when you're
saying okay what should I write about
this week you just go into those replies
and say oh John is struggling with
thumbnails let me write an answer to his
question and then make it a little more
generic so it fits for everybody and
that send it out to the newsletter and
so the way this works in a flywheel
basically the more people who come in
the more frustrations I collect which
gives you more ideas for Content which
as I publish that content reaches more
subscribers